[Music]
we were talking in the break about an
event we went to and your partner David
was there indeed you've got to meet him
and he's a terrific guy and and and then
I find out that you two are pals with
Elton John and his partner David David
Furnish we are very close friends
actually we let them know like we hadn't
told anyone we were having kids and we I
ran into David Furnish on a trip and
always we've just confided in surprise
to tell you we're having kids through
surrogacy in a couple months and he kind
of blanched and he looked around to make
sure really no one was paying attention
and he said we're having a kid through
surrogacy like on Christmas Eve
Wow and so we've sort of bonded through
kids so or so did everyone keep the
secret yeah for sure
or did elton sing a song about it that
night is that how it creates a song yes
that's how he creates his song he hears
a secret no one wants total gets on the
piano and goes well there's a picture of
all four of you at an event yeah and
everything seems not the best picture of
David yeah he's gone oh but look at this
someone this was online a bit people
were I know we were going yes
welcome everyone was wondering about
this
looks like your bottom is being groped
it is getting a little honking yeah
honked a little bit yeah well I know is
that the did you know that was going on
at the time or is your yeah where are
you dead from the waist down dead from
the waist down
why is my device doesn't work I liked it
you know it likes a good Goosen I don't
know that was like I suddenly became a
story like it was like ho no he touched
his bum but I guess that do it when
you're gay you kind of get the bum
touching free card it's two straight
couples right and the guys were honking
the girls butts that would sell would be
like terribly offensive yes but it's a
king with the gay guys it's like even
baseball when they slap each other on
the butt just cupping my bum that's all
he's doing
wasn't digging deep or anything digging
deep gross oh my god that would have
been a picture yeah now that's a story
it's a story see I'll see you in the
lobby later well sign autographs